hello I'm Charles Melton and I'm here
with wired autocomplete interview who is
Charles melted a Korean American
currently in San Francisco who loves
sports especially football who's in a
movie called the Sun is also a star that
is very proud of the military kid army
Brett third culture loves kimchi loves
Korean barbeque I could talk about
myself all day but I'm not going to who
does Charles Moulton play in Riverdale
easy raging mantle who did Charles
Melton playing Glee his name was Gavin
45 seconds episode 5 season 5 New York
New York 43 minutes in you'll see me for
45 seconds so don't take a bathroom
break but that's me who is Charles
multivator my girlfriend and what kind
of question is that people Adam Brittany
the next one Charles Milton what's a fun
fact about me I can do this Smeagol
voice gone from The Lord of the Rings
okay Oh lilo and Stitch - since we're on
a roll right now
Ohama Ohama knows formal family thoughts
left
blah okay when did Charles Melton
graduate I graduated high school in 2009
does Charles Melton speak does Charles
Milton speaking Korean yeah today now
hung up my my date took all my day not
my joke Oh Mario does Charles Martin
speaking crane
can charles Melton sing in my upcoming
film the son is also a star I do sing
crimson clover and in Korean karaoke my
number one song to sing is halo by
Beyonce Charles Melton and Ariana Grande
Charles Melton in Ariana Grande video is
that a statement or is that a question
yes I mean the ariana grande music video
what
give me the next board sorry I'm
starting to get like kind of aggressive
but I'm just kidding guys how tall is
Charles Melton alright well
wikipedia says I'm 511 that's not true
I'm six and a half feet tall so I round
up I'm 6 1
how did Charles Melton become famous it
all started back in Manhattan Kansas the
little apple I was an all-star football
player two years in a row the population
of my hometown is about 70,000 now I'll
state both waves all Centennial we call
Flint Hills that's when I made it how to
get Charles Melton hair don't shampoo
and condition sweat in your hair just
messy mess with it
people are trying to figure out my hair
secrets is Charles Melton I get it I
know he gave me
what does Charles Milton's nationality
well my mother's green she's helping
home first generation one long side and
my dad is American he's Caucasian but
ancestry dates back to there's Charles
Milton vegan no I'm not
I had delicious steak the other day miss
Charles Moulton a dancer finally I can
dance I can dance
what no I don't even music to dance
that's all I got right now miss Charles
Melton leaving River Doh no I'm not
leaving River Dell fans are the best
fans in the world I wouldn't be where I
am right now in this moment if it wasn't
for River Doh I'm very grateful for that
where does Charles Melton left well I
live in Vancouver and I'm once out of
the air because that's where we film
Riverdale and when I'm not living there
I'm living in Los Angeles California on
I'm not gonna tell you where did Charles
Melton go to college Kansas State
University I played football for Coach
Bill Snyder if you ever meet anybody
that says they're a fan of college
football and they don't know who Bill
Snyder is then this should have wined -
where was Charles Melton born I was born
in Juneau Alaska my dad was at the Gulf
War in 91 and it was my mother's first
year in America
she's never been my father got her
one-way ticket did you know Alaska with
his mom three sisters that she's never
met and spent lived with him for a year
I spent my summers up into the eighth
grade up into 15 and you know Alaska
we'd see like kill whales and humpback
whales and yeah Alaska's really
beautiful in the summer time where did
Charles Melton live in Kentucky military
base and Kentucky in Kentucky called
Fort Campbell thank you so much for
listening and bearing with me and
letting me share with you a few moments
I've had a lot of fun doing this and
have a great day